los síntomas del cáncer de seno pueden
variar de una mujer a otra sin embargo
hay varios signos comunes es posible que
note un cambio en la forma en que se
sienten sus senos o pezones puede
presentarse un bulto o sensibilidad en
el pezón otro síntoma puede ser un
cambio en el aspecto del seno o pezón
entre los síntomas frecuentes se observa
cambios en el tamaño o forma del seno un
pezón que se va hacia adentro cambios en
la textura de la piel del seno areola o
pezón o flujo líquido del pezón en
muchos casos el cáncer de seno
diagnosticado de manera temprana
generalmente no causa dolor sin embargo
siempre deberá visitar al médico ante la
presencia de algún dolor en el seno o
cualquier otro cambio que perciba de
forma persistente